this is a topic that is tricky for me
because I don't know as far as soldiers
go and probably one of the more liberal
soldiers you're ever going to meet I
really like the idea of everything being
completely gala Therrien but this is the
one topic that I have the most difficult
time trying to reconcile is the short
answer is no I absolutely do not think
women should be in the infantry and if I
had to boil it down to a single reason
there's guys will list a whole all kinds
of reasons about why it's not a good
idea for women would be in the infantry
some of them I guess have more weight
than others but I think from me the
single I've had a boil it down to one
thing it would be just that it's easier
to maintain discipline a bunch of dudes
if there's no chicks anywhere it's a
bottom line because and that I know
irrigates my friends when I say that but
you know if I'm honest when I'm doing my
job in the army there's not using going
to be a lot of girls around and then
whenever there is that's where all my
focuses especially if i'm working with
her i'm thinking what can i do how can I
sleep with this girl that's all that I'm
thinking about and then after that that
I'm sort of thinking about my mission or
Canyon make sure that I'm you know
covering my sector and killing bad guys
and what have you how can I sleep with
this girl I mean I think it's like the
reason when you have like boys schools
or you know all-girls schools it's just
to like remove the distraction then of
course there's other reasons that come
into play the hygiene is kind of a deal
psychologically it can be very difficult
for guys working with women especially
at the women are lost in combats there
can be kind of infighting role you know
love triangles it's I mean the list kind
of goes on and on but I don't have a
good solid intellectual answer that I
can tell you that I feel good about all
I can say is I just don't like working
with women that capacity I like being
able to be kind of like a barbaric pig
well I'm carrying a rifle be complete
primal and just leave it at that and not
have to apologize for any of it
I think Don't Ask Don't Tell is a stupid
fucking policy and I can't wait for the
repeal that shit it's just lame I mean
there's I mean there's countless times
in which extremely qualified soldiers
have been outed for whatever reason and
then we're allowed to even like there's
been a lot of articles about this at
times officers we're completely
competent who like we're in desperate
need of certain jobs but then it's like
we're kicking people out because we're
not fans of their personal sexual
practices it's just dumb guys homophobia
is still kind of alive and well in the
military especially in combat arms and
it's you kind of have to appreciate how
that affects the perceived morale
soldiers are really really do still kind
of freaked out about the idea of
homosexuals being able to serve openly
in these jobs we work together very very
closely and it's I can appreciate that
it can't be completely it can't be
initially it can't be them dismissed out
of hand if even if I i think that the
way of thinking is maybe uninvolved it
doesn't matter it's still very prevalent
and it's important my humble opinion I
think that if Don't Ask Don't Tell is
repealed I don't think it's going to
change the culture of the military very
noticeably at all it's not like there's
going to be some huge influx of queens
you know are going to like enlist the
military different point there may be
people to do that but I don't think it's
going to be an issue there's not going
to be guys just coming out of closet
left and right it's not going to destroy
morale it's going to be business as
usual you might occasionally have a guy
who you know is open about it and it
changes nothing because you've already
been working with the guy for 20 years
or whatever and you like him it's like
oh well gosh I guess it's not a big
deals I thought it was and life goes on